[ROCK MUSIC]
[PHONE BUZZING]
TOM MELENDEZ: Eh, I'll
get to that later.
[THEME MUSIC]
Good morning, folks.
OK, adjust that for your
time of day, I suppose.
Hi.
I'm Tom Melendez.
And this is next in a
series of short videos
showing you how you can use
Ansible with Google Cloud
Platform.
If you saw our first
couple of videos,
you'll recall the
theme of these videos
is that I'm a DevOps
engineer using
Ansible to manage infrastructure
for our satellite imagery
project.
Earlier, I received
a text letting
me know about an unexpected
traffic surge on our imagery
website.
But we're autoscaling with
Google Cloud Platform,
so I could keep playing my game.
Dylan Silva is here
from Red Hat again,
joining me to talk about
how we're using Ansible
to manage our infrastructure.
DYLAN SILVA: Hi, all.
Tom, thanks for having me again.
Can you describe the setup?
And then I'll be
happy to walk us
through the Ansible playbooks,
like we did the last time.
TOM MELENDEZ: Sure.
Google Compute
Engine not only has
VMs, like we saw
in the last video,
but it also has lots of
networking capabilities.
In this video, we'll
walk through how
we're using GCE's
HTTP load balancer
to create a globally
accessible, cross-region,
auto-scaling website
running on managed VMs,
all provisioned
with the Ansible.
I'm going to kick off
the provisioning process,
and then hand it over
to Dylan to walk us
through these Ansible playbooks.
You can watch our first
video if you need tips
on setting up Google
Cloud Platform or Ansible.
DYLAN SILVA: OK, so
while that's running,
let's take a look at some
of the playbooks, shall we?
TOM MELENDEZ: Sure.
Let me open it up.
DYLAN SILVA: All right.
So now that that's
open, it looks
like we have a playbook
that executes commands
from local hosts and
includes some variables
from various files
like last time.
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
You can run this
command from anywhere,
as long as you have
the proper credentials.
DYLAN SILVA: OK, cool.
So first, we're creating a
couple of managed instance
groups.
We set the name and zone, as
well as the starting size,
and we're also
setting the instance
template that should be used in
building these new instances.
And then it looks like
the managed instance
group, also where you configure
the auto-scaling policy,
is here as well.
TOM MELENDEZ: Yes.
DYLAN SILVA: OK, so that's
one of the greatest features
that I think are there
about scaling applications
with Google Cloud Platform.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about auto-scaling and depth?
TOM MELENDEZ: OK.
Well, with auto-scaling,
you can have
your host scale
up or down, based
on a policy you configure.
The policy can be based on
things like CPU utilization
or what fraction of the
load balancer utilization
the instance group
should handle.
You can even define policies
using custom metrics,
if those don't suit you.
DYLAN SILVA: And details
are in documentation, right?
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
To keep it simple, we
went with CPU utilization.
This policy basically
reads, "scale accordingly
to keep the CPU utilization
on the machines under 80%."
DYLAN SILVA: And that's it?
GCP will scale up those
instances for you?
TOM MELENDEZ: Yes,
to the max number
of instances that you specify.
DYLAN SILVA: That's great.
So I see we specified two
managed instance groups here
with basically the
same configuration.
TOM MELENDEZ: Very true.
We wanted to be
explicit here, but one
might consider using a
looping construct, like
with items or with [? depth. ?]
DYLAN SILVA: And then finally,
for our managed instance group,
we have [? name and ?]
port specified.
TOM MELENDEZ: Yes.
Those are where
the backend service
will send the traffic to.
DYLAN SILVA: Great segue.
So let's talk about
backend services.
What is a backend service for?
TOM MELENDEZ: Basically,
a backend service
is a collection of
interest groups.
The backend service
lets the administrator
treat all of these
instance groups
as a single entity in terms
of serving capability.
DYLAN SILVA: So what
do you mean by that?
TOM MELENDEZ: Well, we've
configured the managed instance
groups to scale up
based on CPU previously.
But really, we haven't
talked about how much traffic
we want them to handle.
By grouping these instance
groups into a backend service,
We can set additional
configuration, as well as
a health check on
the whole entity.
DYLAN SILVA: And then you can
have multiple backend services,
I imagine, right?
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
This lets admins build out
their desired infrastructure,
placing groups of instances
where it makes sense for them,
and determining how much
traffic they should handle.
DYLAN SILVA: Wow, this
really seems super powerful.
TOM MELENDEZ: It is.
Another powerful and
customizable feature
is the URL map, which
we have up next.
DYLAN SILVA: So now it looks
like all of the configuration
here is pretty minimal.
It looks like just
giving it a name
and handling the backend
service that we created.
What is URL map for anyways?
TOM MELENDEZ: You're right.
In this case, and for
many applications,
a simple configuration,
such as this, is fine.
In essence, the URL map maps
the URL to a backend service.
We don't do it here, but you
can route different paths
to different backend services.
DYLAN SILVA: So for
our configuration,
this playbook is
basically saying
map any URL to the default
backend service, right?
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
Next is a target proxy, which
terminates the connection
from the client and routes
the request to a URL map.
In this case, we're
using an HTTP proxy.
DYLAN SILVA: So we could then
change that to an HTTPS proxy
and then still use the
same URL map though, right?
TOM MELENDEZ: Correct.
In that case, you would
also specify the SSL cert,
in addition to a URL map.
DYLAN SILVA: And then
finally, create a static IP
address and a forwarding rule.
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
Up until this point, we've
built out the load balancing
capability.
Now we're creating an IP address
and mapping to the proxy.
DYLAN SILVA: Gotcha.
So when a client makes
a request to this IP
address on that port, the
proxy's going to handle it.
TOM MELENDEZ: Yep.
And that's the entire
configuration for a global load
balanced web application.
DYLAN SILVA: So cool-- not
a whole lot of configuration
then.
How'd the provisioning go?
TOM MELENDEZ: It was done
a lot sooner than we were.
The load balancer was
created successfully.
DYLAN SILVA: Great.
So how does this look
in the web console?
TOM MELENDEZ: Let's take a look.
Opening up the
dashboard, then we
click on Networking,
then Load Balancing.
Let's click on the Advanced
menu down at the bottom here,
which gives us the component
breakdown that mirrors how
we built that up in Ansible.
We see the global
forwarding rule and the IP
address it maps to.
Under Target Proxies, we see the
proxy name, the type of proxy,
and the URL map to apply.
Clicking on Backend Services,
we see our backend service.
Let's click on that.
DYLAN SILVA: Hey,
cool-- traffic.
So we can see how much
is being served out
of each instance group here.
TOM MELENDEZ: Right.
I generated this traffic
with a Bash one-liner using
[? cURL-- ?] one instance in our
east region, one in the west--
just to demonstrate the graphs.
Interesting note that the
user can click right here
and adjust the
settings if they like.
DYLAN SILVA: But
of course, those
are going to be overwritten
by the playbook the next time
because of the desired
state of the system.
TOM MELENDEZ: Yep, of course.
Well, that's it-- another
quick in-and-out video
showing Ansible and GCP.
Thanks, Dylan.
DYLAN SILVA: You're
welcome, Tom.
Hey, it's been great
showing viewers
how to use Ansible with
Google Cloud Platform.
Are you up for another one?
TOM MELENDEZ: I sure am.
DYLAN SILVA: We've got
more to show you, folks.
So we'll see you next time.
TOM MELENDEZ: And don't
forget to check out
all of our Ansible modules
at the URL in the description
below.
[THEME MUSIC]